today we're talking about trusting your
gut a lot of times your guts pretty
reliable source if I'm walking through
the woods and I see a pack of wolves my
God's going to be like hey run and I
would do that but should you always
stick with your gut instincts know what
to illustrate this point we're going to
look at the Monty Hall problem here's
how it works you're on a game show
you've got three doors behind one a
great prize let's say it's a car like a
really cool car behind the other two
sheep know what you're gonna be one of
those people who's all like Oh a sheep's
a good prize anyway well fine then it's
a dead sheep Belka that's upsetting fine
it's a live sheep undo so you've got to
pick one out of the three doors and we
hit the streets with a tiny game show to
present people with that exact choice
behind one of these wonderful doors is a
brand new car well you're gonna find out
aren't you behind two of the doors is
the sheet what am I gonna do it'll show
you I don't know down the right market
that could be worth the same thing No so
that's not no you don't want to shoot
you don't want to sheep these sheep are
sick so what I need you to do is just
pick a door I highly recommend door
number one don't don't don't you dare
but also door number two is great I'm
gonna go with door number one number
three no more I think we're gonna go
into me two three you just gave us uh no
don't take three look so what are you
talking about three I'm gonna pick door
number two number three so let's look at
the odds of you winning no matter which
door you choose from the start you have
a one in three chance of winning and a
two and three chance of losing each door
on its own offers the same probability
so you've picked your door and crossed
your fingers when suddenly the game show
host opens up one of the doors you
haven't picked to reveal that one of the
sheep is behind it and he gives you the
option to switch your choice I'm gonna
reveal to you oh my god door number
three that's a sheep it Oh see the Sheep
he fainted
Oh combat so knowing that you want to
stick with door number three or switch
to door number two should you switch
even if it feels like you're betraying
your gut instinct
yeah you should switch why well what's
important to know is that if you combine
the probability of two doors you'd have
a two and three chance of winning and a
one in three chance of losing so because
the probabilities have stayed the same
that door you picked initially had a one
in three chance of harboring a sweet new
ride while the other two combined had a
two in three chance but now that one of
those two unpicked doors has been
eliminated that remaining door still has
that same two and three chance so by
switching you're twice as likely to win
does that make sense
here watch how better off people fare
when they switch I pick number two I
want you to draw number two see what
happens you're gonna split into two you
want the brand new it's a no it's a
different sheep and here's a supercut of
all the losers who didn't switch let's
delight in their misery I think I'm
gonna stick to two you're gonna go with
your gut you're sticking with door
number three all two sheep son of a
biscuit
when you first choose it's only one
third of a chance so you actually have a
better chance when you select a new door
see that lady gets it now if it still
doesn't make sense to you let's blow the
whole thing up and say that you were
presented with 50 doors you pick one the
host then opens 48 doors and gives you
the chance to switch are you gonna stick
that one random door you picked or
switch to the one door that the host
didn't open makes a little more sense
kinda yeah
so the next time you find yourself in
one of those classic 3 door scenarios
breathe easy
you got this and that's some cool
science for you it's so cool it's math I
think duh you're right well it's fine
it's still subject in school days Oh